alors vous avez lu tout le journal
d'aujourd'hui vous voulez que je vous
donne des commentaires en ce qui
concerne les sanctions nous voyons ce
que nos collègues occidentaux sont
censés gérer dans une hystérie
militaires il ne cesse d'en parler nous
allons vous punir nous allons sauver
l'ukraine dans le cas de votre agression
et notre riposte sera forte vous
connaissez tous ces propos hystérique et
qui essaiera l'occident de fermer sa
position nous sommes prêts à toute
évolution de la situation nous n'avons
jamais attaqué personne
et chaque fois que nous avons été
attaqués l'agresseur a reçu vers les
postes et en ce qui concerne nos
partenaires occidentaux qui en son temps
peu déboussolée et si je comprends bien
on ne savent pas très bien comment elle
pouvait en sortir de cette impasse ils
se sont tous mis eux mêmes moi je vais
pas spéculer à ce sujet je peux référe
mais encore une fois que nous sommes
près de la façon la plus fiable
protéger les intérêts de notre pays sa
sécurité est la sécurité de nos citoyens
vous avez encore quelques points dans
votre question
à ce qui concerne l'armement et les
armements a livré en ukraine
aulas nous avons une position univoque
nous sommes des partisans du respect
sans condition des accords de 2006 qui
sont actuellement saboté par le cren
l'équateur occidentaux du régime de kiev
le régime ukrainien nous ont confirmés
et dont les américains à propos l'on dit
en iront les rencontres genève qu'ils
ont aux premiers à faire qui est
respecté l'ensemble des mesures prévues
par les accords de minsk avant en ce
concerne le statut particulier de
donbass
moi je me base à ce que cet engagement
reste
sur la table de l'occident et que
l'occident assurera le respect par kiev
des accords de musique et et là on aura
plus de questions à ce sujet j'espère
que ce sera le cas
nous avons déjà concerté le jour mais je
sais pas quelles sont les modalités
protocolaire ce serait d'ici deux
semaines il s'agit de la visite de mon
homologue britannique
nous avons manqué
récemment ayant surtout bergueira et dit
qu'il n'a le temps est déjà étudié la
possibilité d'extension de l'otan se
fait déjà longtemps que j'ai pas opinion
à ce sujet un sujet de ces interventions
parce que mon point de vue il a déjà
perdu le bon sens de l'actualité